yeah welcome a new video and three
minute game against some guy with the
norwegian flag I'm pretty sure it isn't
Carlin they have some other players as
well so on c6 we got a Slav and let's
see what line a 6-line yeah play g3 the
sum was played by Kramnik in in London
okay if I take on d5 now it should be
like the normal fianchetto Greenfeld but
with the a6 plate which shouldn't be too
great internets go here how long okay
it's not too great this a six month but
maybe not hurting black home and some
okay okay now this is an extra move
relief in this structure 86 is even um
decidedly negative just weakening
squares I thought he would play six or
something yeah his ideas to to play five
a sieve
yeah what what is a good plan here let's
try this on the idea special page six if
he go see five takes and I take special
page six I can exchange the bishop which
looks like a good piece and the queen is
not so bad on the C file anyway but I
completely forgot about the porn ah no
okay let's let's open up the position I
just blundered this default born this is
embarrassing so how to get any kind of
play here if i go here then c6 and
defaults hanging maybe maybe this is a
way to to play this I mean of course
it's just just fishing through here I
never intended any of this um what about
B form 23 what about Quincy three
threatening made on g7 I can go whenever
six yeah this is a possibility if I play
B form and take let's play before Bishop
takes Queen takes c6 I think as weird as
it sounds it's maybe not so bad for me
somehow I'm pretty active here okay he
wants to play Bishop be sadness there
some way to fight against dad yeah I can
I can take him
should be seven Queen a four with the
temple let's even learn that's even good
for white yeah quite them out of the
blue I I got I got a good position okay
let's take it what now really am a
question Queen deform could be an idea
24 attacking the rook if the rook moves
de 67 Once Upon probably this is gautam
the the bishop is hanging now e 2 is
also hanging at the end so maybe this
isn't winning a pond but i'll wait wait
wait if i take on 28 and yeah it's still
not not working okay so let's just
continue this all the issues that I've
got 22 minutes I'm two minutes down I
could tape with the night theoretically
at least
yeah we got to a completely completely
even position I just have two minutes
down about it's very as symmetrical okay
this wasn't great really Ruby one we had
moved for me yeah it's not it's all not
the end of the world but it's not doing
much whoops great just some silly trick
but ok it's a it's a it's it's working
ok I'm getting to be a porn yeah I need
to take care of the F 2 square 94 of
causes the issue now the lights are not
great against their pawns or H pawns so
maybe this isn't this isn't so great
what's doing it's just a giving me this
night or what yes he just gave me the
night ok so he's intending to go to f4
of course ok first of all I need to move
he cannot he doesn't manage to go here
so he will get in suits long and loose
even interesting didn't expect that yeah
now he needs to retreat and give me the
material
check check check yeah this was just a
bad game what can you say I mean I first
a blunder to pawn that it got into add
to this end game I overlooked of course
the this tactical 3 trickier and yeah
just just bad get the only thing is I'm
slightly more active with the king but
while winning winning us why this
certainly out of the question normally
here needs to go a 94 probably a bit and
not funny no computer just just likes
white yeah okay I've got I've got da
porn the a porn is not nothing to yeah
this is winning novel why I am not be
too of course was was really bad i mean
this just gives away this piece and now
it's technically easy because i get in
the e3 square and this is just just do
this one yeah i blundered this away but
i played really badly especially
actually nice was with blundering the d4
pawn so um maybe time for for break here
yeah thanks for watching anyway